MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
everyone.
Thanks a lot for coming out.
It is my great pleasure to
welcome Prasad Kaipa to
Authors at Google.
He's here today to talk about
his book, "From Smart to
Wise."
And it's actually a great
honor to have him.
Dr. Kaipa is an executive coach,
mentor, author, and
founder of the Center for
Leadership, Innovation, and
Change at the Union School
of Business.
He is also a long-time part
of Silicon Valley.
He has presented.
He has led executive
development, career-coaching,
everything at multiple different
companies here at
Silicon Valley.
And it's an honor to welcome
him to Google today.
So if we could please all give
him a big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
PRASAD KAIPA: Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I think what today we'll talk
about is to look at why the
smartness is the baseline now.
It is no longer something that
gives us the privilege.
When I was growing up in India,
when I went to IIT,
that was something very,
very special.
Or when I worked for Apple
Computer in the '80s, that was
something very special.
But coming and giving
a talk at Google,
everybody is very special.
Otherwise, they wouldn't
be here.
So from that aspect, it's
like a baseline.
If the smartness is the new
baseline at Google, and many
of the Silicon Valley companies
at this moment, how
would you stay one step ahead?
How do you demonstrate
personal leadership?
That is the theme which
I address a lot more.
So next step I thought I should
look at is, how many of
you think you are smart?
Other people may feel that
you are smart or not.
But from your own perspective,
would you raise your hands if
you think you are smart?
It's an interesting scenario,
because depending on different
cultural context and norms,
everybody has their own
expectations and standards
of whether to raise
their hands or not.
Can you keep it up
for one minute.
OK, great.
So some of you didn't
raise the hands.
I won't exactly ask at this
moment why, but let
me get to the next.
Can you raise your hand if
you think you are wise?
Yeah?
Could be sometimes
[INAUDIBLE].
Interesting.
So definitely smaller number
of hands than smartness,
number one.
Number two, they
went up slowly.
Maybe we associate smartness
with speed,
and wisdom with slowness.
That's a frame pattern
which we'll talk a
little bit more about.
I was curious about that.
Next thing, have you read the
book "From Smart to Wise,"
which I have written?
Any of you?
Have you done--
there is a baseline assessment
which we came up with, which
is a five-minute assessment
on FromSmarttoWise.com.
If you go, there are 18
questions, because you have
not read the book.
Of course, there is also a link
to that to [INAUDIBLE]
to assessment.
You can go there.
I recommend, before you start
the book, if you can actually
do that assessment, then
read the book and
start applying it.
That may, actually the value of
what you need will become a
lot more applicable, and
a lot more grounded in
what you want to do.
So let me start with
a definition.
Because the smartness is the new
currency in the knowledge
age, how do you really
define it?
We defined it in the book,
smartness is the application
of intelligence for
self interest.
So practical smartness is about
using your knowledge to
get ahead, using your knowledge
to become a leader
when other people are not having
the same opportunity,
or to make money, to get
a job, to move ahead--
different ways.
It's all connected with, how
do you make sure your
smartness based off your own
growth and development?
That's traditional, simpler
way to define it.
But of course, smartness is
not just about people.
It is actually something that
is pervading our culture.
For example, this IBM has been
calling this decade as the
decade of smartness.
They're trying to create what
you might call a smarter
planet, and how do we really
begin to use our smartness for
the larger context of
environment, population,
technology, to work
for everybody?
And of course, I don't have to
talk at Google about the
smartphones.
If you notice, I put
the iPhone all
the way in the back.
The other thing is the
smart televisions.
It is not just the
smart television
that is becoming popular.
You are also talking
about smart meters
of different kind.
In California, P&G--
actually, it's PG&E--
introduced smart meters, and
of course, Nest smart
temperature control.
Not just one unit,
one appliance.
Now, everybody talks about an
entire house, an entire
community is becoming smarter.
Because of this pervasiveness
of smartness as the new
currency, I wonder whether the
smartness is a new definition
for dumbness.
Because if you try to really
look at everybody being smart,
you have to focus on something
other than smartness if you
need to get ahead.
So in that context, sometimes
holding back on self-interest,
holding back on being too smart
actually could be wise.
At some level, reflecting,
introspecting, slowing down to
make sure that you have actually
paid attention to the
context of value, and taking
care of people on your team,
taking care of your organization
not just to a
self-interest, could be
considered not just
smart, but also wise.
In fact, when I used to work
with several entrepreneurs and
the venture capital firms in
the Valley, they talked
generally about if an idea has
a 70% chance of success to
make it as an entrepreneurial
success, they say don't do it.
Why?
Everybody in the Valley would be
focusing on something that
has a 70% chance of success.
So that means on the ground,
your entrepreneurial company,
based on that idea, may
not actually fly.
If you reverse it, if an idea
has only 30% chance of
success, but if you can really
put attention to it--
because not many other
entrepreneurs are also
interested in that idea--
you have a 70% chance of success
for making the company
successful.
So what I'm trying to raise is
it is counter-intuitive for
people to be successful in
the age of knowledge.
You have to think outside the
box of, what is in it for me?
How can I be successful
in the short-term?
You may have to be expand your
circle of not only influence,
your circle of interest to
include your team, your
organization, sometimes your
community, and bring in the
context of noble purpose, if
you want to be successful,
with your smartness.
Interestingly, somebody says--
like, of course, William
Shakespeare
puts it quite nicely.
"A fool thinks of himself to be
wise, but a wise man always
knows himself to be a fool
first." So at some level, we
are trying to say, smartness
doesn't cut it to be
successful, let alone in Silicon
Valley, because of
complexity that we live in,
the ambiguity [INAUDIBLE].
Nobody can tell you exactly
what to do, how to do it.
And especially, when Larry comes
up and says, we need to
have it as a 10x, you need
to do 10x thinking.
In Google, it is no longer
sufficient for you to look at,
how do I make incremental
improvement?
If I need to create a
breakthrough innovation, and
if my products and solutions are
always online, even a few
minutes of going out could have
significant headlines,
saying that Google is out for a
few minutes, three, minutes,
two minutes.
In that type of a context, you
have to figure out a way to
say how to be wise.
But becoming wise has got
a lot of connotations.
In the earlier stage, when my
co-author, Navi, and myself,
when we started writing a book,
one gentlemen whom we
were interviewing, he asked us,
do you think you are wise
enough to write the book?
If not, why are you
writing it?
If you are not wise, what gives
you the authority to
talk about wisdom?
That's a very legitimate
question, because everybody in
different cultures have their
own opinions about what it
means to be wise.
Of course, I thought I'll give
some practical examples,
collaborating with the
myths that we have.
People say once you are wise,
you will stay wise.
This gentleman was
head of IMF.
He was pretty much a shoo-in
for the President of France
till he couldn't keep
his clothes on.
Sometimes, nobody talks
about how to use
your wisdom or smartness.
But unfortunately, latest--
what you call--
records say that he's being
charged with all kinds of
charges, which are so demeaning
to what could've
been an IMF president or
a President of France.
So once you are wise, you
cannot stay wise.
This is a grounded, pragmatic,
action-oriented scenario where
every day, you need to take some
steps to ask yourself,
this is a smart approach,
this is a wise approach.
Can I make a wiser decision
today for is?
Can I take a wiser
action today?
That's the only way you can
continue to keep updating on
your wisdom.
The second myth says that age
and maturity make people wise.
General Petraeus was celebrated
general in
Afghanistan.
He was the director of CIA.
But I wonder what happens when
it comes to thinking when you
are doing the largest spy
organization in the world, but
you think some of the stuff that
you do can stay private?
Sometimes, I just don't know.
And of course, we have
the latest hero.
He thinks about what it is,
and there was a nice comic
about a couple of weeks ago.
So if you think that the only
chosen few have access to
wisdom, without a question, what
kind of a wisdom is that?
So I wonder whether the wisdom
is actually a birth rite when
we are young.
If you have children, you do
know, some of the common sense
questions that the children
raise, some of that kind of
comments they make, some of the
honesty and authenticity
children have--
I wonder whether we beat it
out of their system in the
name of socializing, in the
name of politeness, in the
name of what you call emotional
intelligence, in the
name of everything else.
I wonder we try to focus them
more on trying to be smart,
according to all standards, but
let go of the common sense
wisdom that would give them the
larger perspective, little
bit more broader way of
looking at the world.
Now let me get it closer
to the home.
If you take some of
these people--
many people I asked, when I give
talks around the world,
would you call them smart?
Lots of hands went up.
Would you call them wise?
Not many hands went up.
Why is that?
Do we associate wisdom
with age?
Do we assume that only old
people with a lot of gray hair
have to be wise, but if you're
young, you cannot be wise?
Interestingly, we talk to one
of the analysts who used to
work with this gentlemen,
Mark Zuckerberg,
in the early stage.
She said when he came to her
research firm talking about
social network, she was not
at all convinced about his
smartness, let alone
his wisdom.
But a year, year and a half
later, when he came back, she
almost thought it was a
completely different person.
She began to realize within the
year time period, he had
associated himself with a lot
of good advisers, wise
leaders, and he learned.
And because of his learning,
he was able to transform
himself, which is what your
founders seems to have done.
They started it, brought
somebody else in, and then,
when the time is right, and
when they felt they were
mature enough, Larry took
the CEO role again.
So there is a role in which
there is humility; willingness
to say, I need to learn from
others; and willingness to
say, this may not be
the right thing.
Those are some characteristics--
it doesn't matter whether
you're a young or old--
that can come in.
And finally, if you look at some
of these people, I don't
think there will be much of
disagreement if we talk about
their wisdom.
One thing you might want to
think about is, did they give
up their smartness to be wise?
Interestingly, when Navi and I
were looking at the title for
this book, we wanted to call it
"Smart and Wise." That is
when the editor told us, you
guys are writing the book, but
you haven't figured out how to
come up with a wise cycle.
We said, why?
He said, if you call it "Smart
and Wise," where is the hook
in the book.
Why would anybody buy it?
You need to have a title by
creating a journey or a
pathway from smart to wise so
that people get some doubt.
Maybe their smartness is not
good enough, they'll buy it.
So they said, first, it is going
to talk about wisdom,
but you have to be smart in the
beginning to come up with
the right title.
So we are learning that
some of these
are extremely important.
But of course, finally, it is
also important to recognize
wisdom is not about coming up
with answers, but it is about
asking the right questions.
Considering the kind of what
do you do-- whether it is
YouTube, whether it is Google,
whether it is many of the
other things--
your innovation, especially
breakthrough innovation, will
come not by incrementally
tinkering what you already
have, but being able to ask
difficult questions, recognize
your products are online
all the time.
And if you have to make changes,
sometimes you may
have to fail bigger before you
can succeed even bigger.
When you don't have the courage,
when you don't have
the wherewithal, and when you
don't go for the 10x as you
are talking about, the ability
to stay afloat--
let alone the ability to grow
and become bigger and bigger--
is going to be questionable.
But of course, we can talk from
a Google perspective, but
the key it comes down to is
Google is nothing but all of
you, and a few more out there.
That means each one of us have
to take responsibility for
what I'm doing, how will it make
a difference to my team,
my division, my company?
If I can have that larger
perspective, when what you do
becomes successful, you also
become successful with it.
In the book, I call it
enlightened self-interest.
That means if you want to be a
personal leader, if you want
to be extraordinary and be
recognized for what you do,
you have to think about how we
expand that pie, like a game.
Being in Silicon Valley, we'll
use another metaphor, right?
I'm sure you're all
familiar with it.
Many times, when smart people
get together to create an
entrepreneurial company, they
talk about, what is your
share, what is my share,
what is the investor
share, and all of them?
One gentlemen taught me.
He said, when you're coaching
these people, you need to help
them to see--
even if you have 70%
of the grape--
70% share of a small company
doesn't mean very much.
Your job as entrepreneurial
team is to make that grape
into a watermelon.
When you make the grape into
orange or a watermelon, even
at 5% stake in that watermelon
is going to be many, many,
many times larger
than the grape.
So that means being smart is
looking at what share do I
have, how much stock
do I have?
Being wise means, how can each
of us work together to make
whatever we have into
much bigger?
It shifts the perspective
significantly.
But that doesn't always
come true properly.
Let me give an example of
Microsoft, for example.
In 1999, the Department
of Justice
wanted to break up Microsoft.
And Bill Gates' testimony didn't
go very well, and got a
bad rep for the Microsoft.
Bill Gates stepped down.
He wanted to go ahead and create
the Gates Foundation.
Of course, since then, he has
given away $26 billion, and
went ahead and started
doing something.
And now, he has become, from
a smart Bill Gates, he has
become a wise Bill Gates.
But on the other hand,
he left the Microsoft
to the smart Ballmer.
Just to give some of
his wise quotes.
You might have heard
of some of this.
"There is no chance that the
iPhone is going to get any
significant market share.
No chance." You can see this
on YouTube, by the way.
"Linux is a cancer that the
attaches itself to an
intellectual property sense to
everything it touches." And
this is the classic--
"Google is not a real company.
It's a house of cards."
Very interesting.
And of course, Bill Gates
himself wrote a book on future
of technology called "Road
Ahead." It didn't have any
mention of internet,
by the way.
So sometimes, I wonder there are
more limits to smartness
than we pay attention to.
The key to remember about
smartness is today, you may be
the smartest person in the room,
but tomorrow there are
no guarantees.
Somebody else will come and
take your position.
So it's a moving target.
You can't actually try
to outsmart people
on a constant basis.
It's exhausting, and
it is not worth it.
Second--
smartness is always about either
a vision of the future,
or what you have done
in the past.
Not worth it, because it
doesn't give you the
mindfulness of [INAUDIBLE]
in the present moment.
Third--
what is smart from one
perspective may be foolish
from another, and it doesn't
translate very well to one
culture to another.
You may have to really begin
to think about, maybe
smartness is not the only way
to be successful, and
recognize that knowing and
seeing the patterns ahead of
everybody else is a trap,
because it leads to ultimately
self-denial, because you--
I came up with a phrase called
core incompetence.
Your signature strength of
yesterday that got you to this
job today is nailing your foot,
and prevents you from
going somewhere else.
So where is your foot
nailed to the
floor is in your smartness.
So watch out, and make sure
smartness is not an addiction
that you keep feeding, because
unless you recontextualize it
as wisdom, your personal
leadership does not get
recognized as much as you want
it to be recognized.
So what is this wise
leadership?
How do you really
recontextualize
smartness into wisdom?
I believe the smartness
is like a pendulum--
it swings to two extremes.
One extreme, if it swings, I
call it a business smartness,
like an entrepreneurial
smartness.
The other extreme, what you
call swings, I call it a
functional smartness.
That means I want to be the head
of my staff, I want to be
the chief technologist, I want
to be the CEO, even Nobel
Laureate I had a good to
interview several Nobel
Laureate over a period
of time.
I found out even they get
stuck in one end of the
spectrum or other end
of the spectrum.
The wise leadership is anchoring
the wisdom to your
larger purpose.
when you anchor your smartness
with something larger as
wisdom, then you can swing
from one end to other end
without the loss of face,
because you're no longer
committed to the questions, or
becoming an expert in the
room, but you're willing
to look stupid.
You're willing to ask
dumb questions.
You're willing to ask some
things which other people are
not raising, like emperor
has no clothes.
Because of that, you may be able
to find something very
interesting.
Arno Penzias, one of the Nobel
Laureates, talks about how he
actually ended up getting
a Nobel Prize.
He said once, he was driving
from New Jersey through the
Midwest with his wife and a
nine-year-old daughter.
And who was telling it seems--
why is that when you change
from one radio station to
another radio station,
you have this buzz?
How can you not prevent
this buzz?
You are the physicist,
what can you do?
And where is this coming from?
He said, oh, this is an
electronic noise.
But later, he realized he
doesn't know where the noise
is coming when you are going
from one station to another,
and he spent some time.
He realized, it is an
intergalactic cosmic noise,
which got him a Nobel
Prize for that.
So sometimes, it is extremely
important that smartness gets
us focused on knowledge
and what we know.
But if you want to do 10x
contribution to you or to your
company, you may have ask more
questions, and more questions
for which you have no
clue how to answer.
Then, the ambiguity you have,
the stress that you are
dealing with, and the complexity
of work that we
deal with, that can be leveraged
to gain more wisdom,
instead of proving yourself
to be more smart.
So let me summarize a couple of
things, and I'll give you a
few examples.
Ultimately, leadership--
whether you manage other
people or not--
to be a leader, to be a personal
leader, it all comes
down to three things.
How do you make decisions?
Do you use judgment and
discernment in making decisions?
Second, how do you
take actions?
Are those actions towards your
own benefit, or with an
enlightened self-interest that
benefits your team, your
family, or your organization?
Third, how do you communicate?
Do you communicate saying,
what I talk, I take
responsibility; what you
listen, I have no
responsibility?
That's one way to communicate.
Another one is to look at and
say what I communicate is
based on what you
have received.
It doesn't mean I have to talk
a lot, but maybe much of what
I have to do in communication--
maybe listening, maybe asking
questions, reading your body
language, using a lot more
emotional intelligence,
context sensitivity--
all of this become extremely
important.
Especially when we are smart,
it becomes a lot
harder to do this.
So wise leadership--
we define it as same
intelligence application, but
this time, we ask you
to do two things.
One is reflection on the
context around you.
Second, introspection on the
skills that you bring.
If you can couple reflection and
introspection, and focus
on the larger good--
that larger good could extend
as far as you want it to be.
For Steve Jobs, larger
good extended only up
to he and his company.
But for you, you need
to make a choice.
How much good is larger
good for you?
In other words, it is
repurposing your intelligence
and smart leadership in
the present moment.
It is about being mindful, not
just about the past or the
future, but it is about being
here and now at some level.
What does wise leadership
get you?
It gets you ethical clarity
in times of complexity.
Second, judgment when you
need discernment.
And finally, humility,
recognizing I might have come
up with a great solution today,
but it has happened
because of help with
other people.
And when you honor other people,
when you respect other
people who help you, chances
are that can become a
sustainable relationship.
So let me just give a court,
and ask whether
you have any questions.
And I can give examples of wise
leadership, and I can do
a lot of different things.
But for you to become wise,
there are three
most important stuff.
As I said, reflection is
a very powerful tool.
Second, we call it politically
correct word--
best practices.
We try to look at the
In my book, we wrote a lot of
examples based on interviews
and narratives of various
successful leaders, which is
the easiest.
Third, experience.
What I recommend is once you
complete this talk, actually
think about-- when
you go back--
three areas.
What do I need to communicate
in my project?
What decisions do I need to make
to take the next step?
What actions are imperative
for me?
In both of these scenarios, if
you can think every day at
least one decision, one action,
and one communication.
Is this a smart one,
or a wise one?
Can I begin to take one decision
a day that is wiser,
one action a day that would
move me towards wise
leadership.
I have a feeling over
a period of time--
as somebody said, can I
be wiser sometimes?
I think you raised
the question.
I think that is the way
in which we go.
Even though wisdom may be the
birth rite, because we have
forgotten and got conditioned,
we may have to unlearn and
selectively forget what
we have picked
up, how to be smart.
And step by step, we can make
progress towards wise
leadership.
Let me stops for a minute
and check--
any questions?
Comments?
Yeah, please.
You have a question
in the back.
There is a microphone
coming [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You're not speaking
about being genuine.
And I know that it's embedded in
those concepts, but that is
one particular concept, I think,
first and foremost,
needs to be spoken to.
And obviously, maybe
in your book.
PRASAD KAIPA: I use the word
"authenticity." For example,
Steve Jobs was very authentic,
but he was not necessarily
mostly appropriate.
I think there was a movie that
came out last weekend.
I just saw it.
It was so flat for me, because
I worked for Apple, and I had
known Steve Jobs at
different times.
So for me, it was like, duh.
There wasn't anything
that got into what
made somebody special.
That didn't come through.
So all the key points, all the
checklist has been done, but
there is no learning
that can come.
There is no insight in there.
On the other hand, Tim Cook
is very appropriate.
He didn't care about when he
was number two, Chinese
workers, all of them.
But as soon as he became CEO,
he started paying more
attention to.
But at the same time, he's very
politically sensitive,
politically correct,
wonderful.
But now, some people are raising
questions, is he the
right person?
Is he leading Apple
in the right way?
So you may need to think about
when it is appropriate for you
to be genuine and authentic, and
say what you have on your
mind with your team members and
other people, and when is
it appropriate to hold back
your genuine feedback, and
look for the right time
and right place
to give that feedback.
In India, as I grew up, there
is a wonderful proverb that
says, the truth has only meaning
when somebody is
looking for it.
If somebody is not looking for
your genuine feedback, if you
give that feedback, they'll look
at it like a criticism,
only negativity, or you
just don't like me.
So in a negative context,
authenticity and genuineness
is not appreciated as much.
But if you can create a context,
if you were to say,
you know, I see that you
have done one, two,
three very, very well.
And there a couple of things, if
you do, you could even take
it to a whole new level.
If you have interest in it, I
have identified a couple of
suggestions for you.
Let me know when you
want to implement.
I will give it to you.
So what you have done in the
minute, one-minute coaching is
you have created a context for
other people to ask for the
feedback, and recognize that you
have given your positive,
appreciative stance to your
feedback already, and you have
created a gap for them to
really look at, how do I
transcend that gap?
Because they are intentional,
because they are asking for
it, they will receive your
genuine feedback much more
appreciatingly, and they become
friends, and stay friends.
So that is what I think is the
way in which authenticity is
not always good.
You have to watch for it.
That's what I call wisdom is not
about staying on one end
or other end.
It is not right or wrong,
good or bad.
How do you balance it in a way
that is appropriate to the
context, and still being
true to yourself?
Any other questions?
Comments?
Then shall I move on with
a couple more examples?
And then, I can take
more questions.
You can prepare for
that, if you like.
Here is a gentleman, Alan
Mulally I had a good chance to
interact with in Boeing,
and later, in Ford.
He comes out of--
he had aeronautical
background.
At one time, he wanted
to be an astronaut.
And unfortunately, because he
has some eye issue, he could
not become an astronaut.
He was very disappointed.
But then he said, you know, at
least let me make the planes.
So he joined--
from Kansas, he came
to Seattle.
He joined Boeing.
He became the president of
Boeing Commercial Aircraft.
Somewhere down the line, he was
invited to Ford, and that
was 2006 time period.
And then when the financial
malaise hit the nation, most
of the companies took
the bailout--
government bailout.
Instead, Ford went ahead-- and
under the guidance of Alan
Mulally-- took about
$24 billion loan.
They actually had to
get that moniker
mortgaged, that Ford moniker.
Everybody looked at it and said,
isn't it stupid for you
to not take the easy money?
Not only that--
there so many other actions
which it took, everybody
questioned, we should have never
brought that person from
outside the automobile
industry.
What are some of
those actions?
He went ahead, and sold the
most expensive, profitable
Ford businesses, like Land
Rover and Jaguar.
He sold Indian Tata Group.
And Ford was making a lot of
money making trucks and SUVs.
He said, you know, we need to
start focusing on smart cars.
Ford said, we don't
make money on it.
Then he said, you better figure
out how to make money
on the small cars, because
that is the future.
Then he found out that--
what you call--
Ford Taurus, which used to be
a famous car, they shut done
that brand because they said
nobody is buying it.
He said, well, if you have
already built a brand value,
figure out how to come up with
something, and make that brand
value to pay for itself
instead of trying
to build a new brand.
So in more ways than one, he was
very counter-intuitive to
what they were doing
in and out.
But now, five years later, Ford
is much, much more green,
much, much more profitable, and
it is on a path to success
that was unprecedented.
And even when compared to their
competitors, they have
done exceedingly well.
So in that respect, I believe
certain ways in which Alan
Mulally had taken decisions,
taken actions, and how he
communicated are some things
that increase the value of not
only the Ford brand, but
also his own brand.
And some of you might want to
check out Alan Mulally videos.
There are--
Alan Mulally, some of the
articles about him.
He is extremely positive.
When I went to interview him, he
knew more about me, and he
was really preparing various
stuff for me
rather than for himself.
Then when I came out--
actually, it was at Boeing--
I asked the secretary, is
Alan always like that?
He said, yup.
He's always the cheerleader.
For anything he takes on, he's
positive, appreciative,
gung-ho, and 100% into it.
Interesting.
But those are some things which
we don't know how to
deal with sometimes in
different cultures.
You need to think about, what
is your authentic style, and
what appropriate style?
How do you really make it work
in whichever group, whichever
company you are in.
Let's look at the context
sensitivity and discernment
for a minute.
Sam Palmisano, when he took over
IBM in 2002, he saw the
writing on the wall--
PCs are becoming commodities.
Hardware is not where
the energy is.
So what did he do?
He sold the entire PC
business to Lenovo.
He sold the hard disks
to Hitatchi.
He got rid of even the
chips manufacturing.
He completely converted IBM
into services business.
Few years later, Leo
Apotheker, from
SAP, took over HP.
He tried to do the same thing.
He wanted to get
rid of the HP--
what you might call the
hardware business.
Even though they bought the
Palm for $1 billion a year
ago, within a month of
introducing the Palm Tablet,
he closed it down.
Of course, they closed him down
before he had a chance to
do more of what they called
damage to HP.
What was smart at one time was
no along wise by the time it
came to Apotheker.
That means you cannot just
blindly follow successful
people, even though they may
be your bosses, they may be
your seniors, or someone else.
You will have to pay attention
to what is appropriate, and
use discernment and judgment
to make it work.
In India, when I studied,
there was a gentleman.
This gentleman--
called Dr. V., for a short
way to think about--
he created, after he retired
as an eye surgeon
at the age of 55--
he said, I'm too young
to retire.
I want to make a contribution
to the world.
So he converted his family
housing to an 11-bed hospital.
And he convinced everybody he
knew in his family and his
friends to becoming the eye
doctors, or to provide eye
medicine supplies, or to create
an organization, or to
create training.
As of last year, Aravind Eye
Care is the largest eye care
system in the world, operating
at one 10th the
cost of United Kingdom.
They provide more services
than the entire
United Kingdom provides.
Just to give you a comparison,
they got license for the
cataract lenses.
They got the patent from the
United States, they got the
license from United States.
Same cataract lenses
are being sold for
$150 in United States.
In India, they offer
it for $2.
I was told it has come
down to $1 now.
And for every one paid surgery,
they do two free surgeries.
Check out this book, "Infinite
Vision." It is written by
[INAUDIBLE], one of the authors
actually lives in
[INAUDIBLE].
So when you have a larger
purpose, when you have a noble
purpose, your smartness
can actually
serve a larger community.
So each of you being
extraordinarily smart, you
might want to think about and
say, where am I contributing?
What is my North Star?
What is my noble purpose?
Where do I want to be 10 years
from now, 20 years from now?
It is good to do 10x
contribution at this moment,
but 10 years from now or 20
years from now, what would you
like to say to your children--
and for some of you later than
that-- maybe to your
grandchildren, what have you
contributed to the planet?
If you can begin to think
about it, then your
performance--
whatever do today, tomorrow--
it will come with a purpose.
That is what Indra Nooyi
did in PepsiCo.
Not only they are looking at
making the drinks, Coca Cola
drinks, and pizza,
and all of them--
doing food, what you
call a fun food--
it's OK.
They said, we want to get more
profit from good-for-you
foods, not just fun-for-you
foods.
Because of that, they've went
ahead and said, we buy Quaker
Oats for oatmeal.
We want to create more kinds
of healthy food.
Of course, their own stock
holders don't like it.
So she's actually fighting
sometimes for her own
position, because everybody
wants you to make money right
now, but they don't care about
anything-- where it goes, and
how it happens.
So at some level, you need to
look at it and say, how do you
reconcile your long-term
vision with
your short-term delivery?
That is where the
wisdom comes.
You cannot just say, I will only
focus on the vision; or
you cannot just say, I will
only focus on quarterly
results of what I need to do.
The wisdom is to be able to
balance both of them, and
align your head and your
heart and the hands.
When you bring that alignment,
the wisdom is something that
actually naturally emerges
in all of it.
So again, Steve Jobs
and Ron Johnson
created the Apple Stores.
But as you know, he tried to
take it to JC Penney, and
tried to apply the same recipes
of no sales, focusing
on marketing, and creating
stores within stores.
Again, he got booted out,
because what worked for Apple
didn't work for JC Penney.
So you need to have, again,
three things which I said
about personal leadership.
Am I having a discernment and
right judgment to use what
needs to be used
where and when.
I can't use what made me
successful in Apple
stores in JC Penny.
Remember, I used the word
core incompetence?
You need to ask yourself,
whatever got you this job, for
you to go beyond it, you have
to see where is your foot
nailed to the floor.
Most chances are, your foot is
nailed to what got you the
success the last time.
Think about your success formula
Think about your
winning formula, and see what
you need to learn beyond that.
And here is another lady, who is
considered to be one of the
richest entrepreneurs in India,
Kiran Mazumdar-Shaw.
She has a company called Biocon,
and she focused on
oral insulin.
When it didn't work out, she
realized her focus is on
actually diabetes therapy.
She cannot become very anal
about one of the product, and
lose focus on the big picture.
So last thing which I'll say
is Ratan Tata, the guy who
bought the Jaguar and Land
Rover, he also realized it is
not just the most expensive cars
that he needs to sell,
but being in India, he wants to
make automobiles affordable
to everybody.
So he came up with a car which
costs only $2,000.
Right now, it has become even
cheaper because a dollar is 62
rupees right now.
So that means, for $2,000,
he could do.
Marketing didn't work out very
well, because he called it a
poor man's automobile.
So not poor men want to buy it,
because they want to buy a
rich person's automobile.
They don't want to buy a
poor man's automobile.
So marketing kind of messed
up a little bit.
But I have a feeling the concept
really caught on, and
there are many other companies
are beginning to make it.
This is an example of
enlightened self-interest--
you have everything what you
have, but question is, how do
you support other people?
So in my book, I talk
about any of this.
But right at this time, I would
love to take questions.
Yeah, please?
AUDIENCE: You touched upon it
a little bit, but if you can
expand in more detail about the
barriers from going from
smart to wise.
Especially in the context of,
you have a vision, you're
looking at the bigger picture,
you're looking beyond
self-interest, and more for
community or for your company
or your family.
Of course, the people who are
around you that should be
supporting you are the
biggest barriers.
And how do you overcome
these ones?
PRASAD KAIPA: OK, thank you.
One action orientation.
Smartness is about thinking,
wisdom is about doing.
Wisdom is always here and now.
Smartness is always about the
future you are creating.
So you need to realize that the
wisdom will not come by
reading out of a book.
But if you can-- let us say,
some of you, because you got
the book as you came in--
let us say you create
a small book club.
Start talking about every week,
one chapter, or one part
of a chapter, and see how you
can apply it in your immediate
work or in your family
outside.
Try to share those things.
You can even create
a Google Hangout.
You can create some of other
ways of sharing it.
Begin to apply one
step at a time.
If you can do that, chances are
90 days from now, you will
be much wiser.
But you see, saying that
is much easier.
I'm sure you have hundred
reasons why you don't have
time, you don't have enough
people, it takes energy--
you have too many things on
your plate to be able to
organize any of this stuff.
So what it means is, one,
it is cognitive framing.
Don't look at wisdom as
something away from
what you are doing.
As a matter of fact, whatever is
written about in the book,
or what I'm talking about, is
about application of what
you're doing in a smarter,
in a wiser way
right now, right here.
So wisdom is not just
about long-term.
So that is one thing
you need let go.
That means focus
on applying it.
Second, do it with other people,
because wisdom grows
when you have multiple
questions, and people
challenge you.
It is not about showing off
how smart you are in the
group, but asking questions so
that all of you can learn.
Wisdom multiplies
and synergizes.
So that is something which is
hard for people to look at.
Third one I found is a barrier,
if several times we
look at, it is outside of
what I'm supposed to do.
I will do this, and if I have
time, I will read the book.
If I have time, I will apply
it, without recognizing
whatever you have to make
it more executable, more
successful, you need wisdom.
Because as you saw Larry doing,
it is not about adding
more projects that makes
Google successful.
It is about removing certain
things which are not having a
high impact, and focusing on a
smaller number of them with
the discernment, and making them
deeper, more profound,
more meaningful, and more
higher quality.
For that, you need
discernment.
So similarly, if you can begin
to recognize, acting with
wisdom, you have everything
what it takes.
You did just that.
You need to put it
in practice.
Acting with smartness, you
may need more knowledge.
You may need to read more, or
you may need to actually talk
more, or do something else.
These are three major barriers
I have seen.
Many smart people, despite
having the resources--
time, our cognitive framing,
and third, application--
this are some things which you
need to pay attention.
AUDIENCE: So I'm just wondering
how you applied all
these concepts in your own life,
and my significant parts
of your life where you
decided, OK, this is
more wise to do?
PRASAD KAIPA: OK.
Well, my daughter says--
like, I remember when
she was in school.
I traveled so much that one
day, I came in and she was
going to school.
And I was reading paper early
morning, and she was busy
getting ready.
And then my wife was there, and
we were talking, and she
my wife was giving me update
on what happened during the
week that I was gone.
I was saying, uh-huh, and then
continuing with the newspaper.
My daughter comes in and says to
me, why do you keep saying
uh-huh when you're reading
newspaper as if somebody is
listening to you reading it?
Then I put my best, caring,
patronizing tone, and I said,
sweetheart, your mother is
giving me an update.
I'm acknowledging her.
It is not quite to listen
without acknowledging.
She said, Dad, you talk
about communication.
My mother has gone to bathroom
five minutes ago.
Now I know how much
you are listening.
What I learned was that more
you talk about wisdom, the
lack of it shows up a lot more
clearly to other people.
But what I'm learning is, places
where nobody's paying
attention to me, places where
I am not in front of other
people, that is where actually
I have an opportunity to
contribute, and learn,
and grow.
So I'm paying a lot more
attention to learning from
home, and paying attention to
areas where I can make a
contribution, just because
I want to learn,
and I want to practice.
So I should also say, after my
colleague and myself, we
finished the book,
I have learned a
lot more about wisdom.
And I'm ready to do 2.0 the book
already, because some of
these are all based on
practical stuff.
But I'm also learning which of
these are easier for me to
practice, which of these are a
little harder to practice.
So that is how I'm beginning to
make a move myself, to take
what I have written and apply
it in my own life.
And it is working.
That is one thing.
Most of the time, I used to
say, what you write is for
others, what you learn
is for yourself.
But I'm actually been figuring
out that some of what we have
learned from others, I can
apply it for myself.
So this book is as good for my
own learning as it is for
other people.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so with
that, I think we're
almost out of time.
So once again, I'd like to thank
Dr. Kaipa for coming and
talking to us.
And if you have any more
questions, or would like your
book signed, I believe he has
some more time to sign your
copies of the book.
So if we could all thank him.
[APPLAUSE]